oder du hast seinem tod und den tod
seiner tochter auf dem gesäß oder
geschickt bekommen zu einem neuen low
ash führen wir jetzt mal die haare
[Musik]
wir hier oben schon die ganze reihe wird
jetzt seht es dass ihr ein wäre video
und zwar ein weiteres video der gugl
play game und kampagne und ich schon
verschiedene spiele gespielt wie
beispielsweise des films asphalt 9 oder
wort ich heute kein normales spiel wie
irgendwie ne rennspielen oder ein
abenteuerspiel irgendwas sondern wir
spielen einen chat mehr oder weniger und
müssen einen kriminalfall aufklärung das
spiel was wir heute spielen heißt in
essen bzw
innocent und das ganze ist aufgebaut wie
einen chat als wir müssen mit
verschiedenen leuten chatten uns mit
diesen leuten unterhalten und nebenbei
noch eine mord serie an jugendliche
aufklären und weist euch jetzt wagen
sollte genug bist du das nicht machst du
so einen blog
die leute mit denen wir chatten werden
im heutigen video und in diesem
detektivspiel tvo autostunde zu
antworten deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
mach' ich einen blog in dem ihr heute
milch und gleich eine noch junge den
ganzen tag begleiten werde die wir den
tief spielen werden
die challenge die jugendlichen heute
gegenseitig stellen werden
wer trifft die besseren entscheidungen
also so sieht die app aus wenn man sie
öffnet dass wir aus dieser nachrichten
wir haben eine nachricht von steller die
ist einfach als unsere ex eingespeichert
ich habe heute von dir geträumt youtube
wir haben uns vor mittlerweile fünf
jahren getrennt stehen uns aber immer
noch nach ich glaube es tut mir leid wie
alles gelaufen ist
wir haben jetzt möglichkeiten zwei
verschiedene sachen zu sagen war es ein
alptraum oder war es ein guter traum
juli
ich würde sagen du darfst die erste
entscheidung treffen in diesem video ok
unit trifft diese entscheidung mit einer
umfrage hier oben ab
wer von uns beiden wie ihr denkt die
besseren entscheidungen getroffen hat
ein schrecklicher traum ich habe ihn
noch nicht verarbeitet und wir haben
wieder auswahlmöglichkeiten zu sagen
entweder reden wir über etwas weniger
ernstes ok oder wenn du es mir nicht
sagen willst musst du nicht ich sagt was
reden wir über etwas weniger ernst es
die beziehungen verschlechtert sich
er schreibt nein ich muss jemanden davon
erzählen du und ich wir sind in unserer
alten wohnung ich liege auf dem bett und
du sitzt am computer wie gewöhnen
ich schaue dir zu und versuche
einzuschlafen plötzlich spüre ich wie
jemand versucht mich zu ersticken ich
versuche nach die zu rufen aber ich
schaffe es nicht ich kann mich nicht
bewegen und ich kann nicht schreien das
atmen fällt mir immer schwer obwohl da
niemand ist es war einfach diese
schreckliche gefühl der hilflosigkeit
hat die hatte echt ein alphorn du lachst
jetzt schon für ihre nächste nachricht
entschieden und war wie ich gefragt wie
ging es weiter und diese stelle hat
geantwortet das wurde mir schlussendlich
auch klar ich konnte nichts dagegen tun
es war furchteinflößend und dann warte
ich auch also das war es von ihrem traum
und ich kann mich jetzt entscheiden
zwischen dass das wirklich schrecklich
oder aber jeder halb träume vergiss es
ich mach das jeder die mittels jung
verschlechterten ich mach alles falsch
alter also die schwester von unserer ex
freundin stella heiratet in einem monat
und stella fragt uns gerade wie die
begleitung sein wollen von ihrem ich
kann entweder schreiben tut mir leid
dass ich hochzeiten hasse oder ja warum
nicht ich hoffe ich muss nicht mit tante
semra tanzen
ich nehme das kommt mir die beziehungen
verbessert werden
kathrein bekommen hat uns nachricht
geschrieben bei karl steht die erklärung
mein alter freund nach der tragödie mit
seiner frau gab es nur einen einzigen
grund für ihn weiter zu leben wer dachte
nur an seine tochter emma und karl
schreibt verdammt sie lässt nicht meine
tochter nicht sehen obwohl heute laut
gesetz mein tag ist sie behauptet er sei
krank
also er darf seine tochter nicht sehen
heute juli kann man entweder antworten
das tut mir leid oder vielleicht ist
aber wirklich krank
sie schreibt das tut mir leid die
beziehung verbessert sich hawking genie
und ich werde bald wieder nach hause
holen ihr platz ist bei ihrem vater das
sehen die behörden aber anders nicht
wahr und ja du hast dich in letzter zeit
geändert ich mache das andere aber ich
glaube dadurch nein jedes mal wenn ich
was sage verschlechterte erziehung der
karl hat auf jeden fall einige
smartphones zugeschickt bekommen und man
kann das selber rein investieren also
man kann fünf münzen oder zehn münzen
investieren und bis zum meer man
investiert das merke man kaufen und
wieder verkaufen
wir haben jetzt einfach mal zehn münzen
investiert wir hatten genau zwanzig
halles offline aber wir haben neuen chat
und zwar bis 20 4 6 0
[Musik]
so wurde von gott auserwählt deine hände
sollen gerechtigkeit üben benutzer
offline
was ist wenn wir auf details klicken
gesichert keine daten aufgezeichnet
ich bin hier eingeschlossen hilfe ok und
schreibt die 15.000 ich verstehe nicht
was hier vorgeht okay jetzt stehe ich
drüber glaube ich ins ernste wird das
vorhin waren nur die normalen schätzen
die auch unseren händigkeit angezeigt
wurden also irgendwie von drei ex
freundin oder von dem kahl als ein
kumpel von uns und jetzt
er hat uns eine unbekannte nummer
geschrieben dass ich gott sei und eine
andere nummer hat uns geschrieben dass
diese person eingeschlossen als julia
ist dran und kann sich entscheiden
zwischen ist das ein scherz und ich
verstehe es auch nicht wer bist du wir
haben jetzt ist das ein scherz
geschrieben und die person dessen nummer
wenig haben antwortet man hat mir deine
nummer gegeben sie schreibt auch
weiterhin und schreibt ihr name ist
erwünscht
darin schreibt er wurde entführt er sagt
mein schicksal liegt in deinen händen
ich weiß nicht wo ich bin oder wie ich
hierhergekommen bin es ist dunkel und
heiß sie haben mich irgendwo
eingeschlossen keine ahnung wo hat er
okay der erwin ist der entführte juli
kann jetzt nur antworten beruhige dich
ich werde die polizei rufen ich hoffe
dass das kein scherz ist und der
benutzer softline okay wir haben eine
nachricht bekommen von dem anderen user
der schreibt denkt nicht mal daran keine
polizei der körper oder du hast seinem
tod und den tod seiner tochter auf dem
gewissen
im bild geschickt ich hole
okay das ist eine person sitzend auf dem
boden frage ist nur wie hat der er wie
uns immer auch dem bild ja decke ein
handy also dieser guss ist ein kumpel
von uns der ist hacker oder schreibt du
kannst sie ausnutzen dann sind wir quitt
beendet den chat und mache einen anruf
rufe diese nummer 1 drückt dann die 1
und dann die drei dann den code 4815
bekommst den münzen und wir sind quitt
darauf haben wir geschrieben das schön
ich werde es versuchen ich habe einen
auftrag für dich ich muss den standort
von zwei telefonen finden ihre id
nummern sind die von diesem erben und
dieser andere nummer ich habe jetzt
keine zeit dafür tut mir leid aber du
kannst das alles selbst machen
wir hätten uns jetzt hier gerade in die
messenger datenbank die haben das ganze
bisher zwölf prozent abgeschlossen
das heißt wir werden uns jetzt die
nächsten zwei oder stunden ohne dass das
blogger damit beschäftigen versuchen uns
da rein zu hacken sondern sehen wir uns
wieder wenn wir das geschafft haben
bei der lieben zuschauer wir haben die
rätsel gelöst oder bzw
diese spiele gespielt haben dadurch ein
bisschen münzen gesammelt und wir haben
nun neue nachricht bekommen person die
entführt wurde hat uns geschrieben bist
du noch da glaubst du mir bitte lass
mich nicht allein möchtest du schreiben
okay kannst du mir sagen wo du bist und
du dahin gekommen bist oder kannst du
den entführer beschreiben
dieser ort ist immer dunkel der hat mich
von hinten überwältigt als ich zu meinem
wagen ging ich bin hier aufgewacht er
gab mir ein telefon und sagte wenn ich
am leben bleiben möchte bist du der
einzige der mich retten kann und dass er
mich und meine tochter tötet wenn die
polizei alarmiert wird hier gibt es kein
mobilfunksignal und das einzige was auf
diesem telefon funktioniert ist dieses
programm und der einzige tag den ich
habe bist du der benutzer ist offline
werden jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen
mit karl geschrieben und jetzt gerade
hat uns der anführer wieder eine
nachricht geschrieben die nachricht ist
gerade irgendwie wieder verschwunden
aber er hat auf jeden fall geschrieben
du sollst mit den ermittlungen beginnen
und wir können wieder sagen ich mir nur
sichergehen dass das kein scherz oder du
hast ein mann entführt du weißt doch
dass das ein verbrechen ist nicht wahr
also dass antworte ich jetzt mal er hat
es gelesen das schon
foto schickt ein foto geschickt was ist
das es sind schüsse
[Musik]
bei alter was ich mache keine witze ich
weiß wie deine freunde und deine familie
wohnen legt sich besser nicht mit mir an
[Musik]
wie du kannst entweder sagen du bist ein
kranker mistkerl oder was willst du der
entführer hat geantwortet ich will
gerechtigkeit es kein opfer erst hier um
für seine verbrechen zu bezahlen
die entführte person hat wahrscheinlich
forschung was verbrochen ich antworte
jetzt einfach wenn er schuldig ist
übergibt ihn der justiz
die werden das schon ihre sache machen
ich es jetzt auch nicht an dass diese
personen hier in die entführt wird die
richter dieser welt sinn macht muss wir
müssen selbst für gerechtigkeit sorgen
benutzer auflaufen
[Musik]
der entführte er den hat uns gerade
wieder geschrieben und er führt uns auch
noch mal geschrieben er wien hat
geschrieben als er wegging konnte ich
vom fenster aus ein foto machen ich
musste ein brett zur seite schieben also
dass hier darauf
da gar nichts schau dir das an hilft dir
das weiter das ist alles was ich
schicken kann die hast du mich finden
also er ist glaube ich an einem haus das
ihr das scheint die sonne drauf und wir
haben aber eine neue nachricht auch
bekommen von dem in für morgen ist ein
besonderer tag für dich nicht wahr
spioniert du mir nach wir müssen jetzt
wieder in der messenger datenbank noch
zwei sterne einsammeln das etwas machen
wenn auch eben und dann schauen wir mal
wie das ganz sicher weiter geht ok ich
bin gerade eigentlich dabei diese level
zu machen doch dann plötzlich kam das
hier unbekannte id eingehende anrufe
soll ich angehen
ich weiß wie man das richtig verstehen
könnte das war relativ leise war seine
kinder nicht und dann hat er einfach
wieder aufgelegt
es ist wieder einige zeit vergangen
freunde ist es mittlerweile halb sehen
und wir haben eine nachricht bekommen
von unserem hacker mister gros der
schreibt hallo hast du die datei über
die wir gesprochen haben das heißt wir
kriegen jetzt mal auf die datei drauf
archiv punkt zip datei und mal abwarten
unser heck gebäudes mit sagt diese datei
scheint keine geo lokation zu enthalten
sehr schade könnten andere hinweise
vorhanden sein ich weiß auch nicht ich
meine ich habe dieses foto von dem ort
und halt dieses foto was wir immer noch
haben man sieht wirklich nur eine
fassade und da sind so eine kleine sohn
kleinen balkon er schreibt jetzt er kann
mit hilfe der metadaten den zeitpunkt
der aufnahme feststellen damit den
winkel und der größe der schatten
vergleichen halter das klingt nach dem
krassen hacker so können wir den ort
bestimmen oder zumindest die allgemeine
region aber es gibt da noch ein problem
wir können nur schreiben welches problem
deswegen was das fotos zu verschwommen
sorry aber das musste der erwin
irgendwie machen heute einen führer sich
weggedreht hat wir brauchen einen
grafiker der ist ein wenig bearbeitet
und die schatten deutlicher macht meine
ex wir haben uns hier mit stella gerade
noch so ein bisschen über die
vergangenheit unterhalten und sie hat
dann geschrieben ok genug über die
vergangenheit ich mache mich jetzt an
die bearbeitung eines fotos benutzer
auch das heißt sie brauchen jetzt
wahrscheinlich wieder ein bisschen bis
sie halt dieses foto richtig bearbeitet
hat so dass wir es dem hacker schicken
können an der stelle für view nicht das
heutige video ist allerdings auch
beenden weil der lieben freunde die
challenge paar zu schauen welche
personen von uns beiden der beste del
aktiv ist und bessere fragen stellt und
ich glaube bleibt gewonnen
damit könnte auch noch einmal hier oben
abstimmen er hat halt die beziehungen
richtig gut aufrechterhalten und ich
habe beziehungen immer nur
verschlechtert wie wir finden uns jetzt
sich allerdings auch in der end karte
des heutigen videos wenn euch dieses
video ihr gefallen hat dann das gerne
mal einen daumen hoch bei diesem video
dann schreibt uns kennt
die kommentare ob ihr eine fortsetzung
wollt also wie wir das bild an den
hacker schicken und nachschauen wie es
weitergeht
an der seite könnt ihr euch das spiel
auch selbst herunterladen und das selbst
mal aus checken und ihr findet auch noch
ein weiteres video von der kampagne hier
verlegt
[Musik]